Tell me to do it right before we do it.
Hold on.
Why aren't they getting this running out
here in the song?
It just sit there on your arm.
But the video's not making sound video
to not make it sound like it's not.
The program's just freaking out to like
get the fuck off the phone.
You live in front of hundreds of people.
I didn't know John [inaudible].
Ladies and gentlemen,
winner of last comic standing.
Not like those faggots he beat.
Yeah.
He's the God damn champion.
We the first champion of laptop.
I was second.
Fuck was the first uh,
Dat fan that fan.
Good old debt.
Was that,
does that in any way diminish your
accomplishment?
What ever happened to that dude?
I don't know what happened to him.
I think he's a,
he does.
Well,
he,
I think he said he does a lot of shows
and the things sell out and stuff like
that.
So kissing his ass.
That's actually a nice guy.
He is taking a lot of guys like to bag
on the guy for it because when he he
wanted,
he was really,
really green and new.
But I don't fault anybody for that.
He's always been nice to me.
He's been nice to meet.
I've never seen him wants to stand up.
And I saw him.
One,
I judge the first last comic standing
and he fucking crushed it.
Did,
uh,
the,
the last,
that was when we caught and stealing
material and that's when I get screamed
at me.
Right,
right.
Almost had a heart attack.
That was a fucked up story because this
dude aunt was stealing jokes,
like book jokes,
jokes at a movies,
old friendships.
And I complimented them first instead of
your really good performer.
You got a lot of energy,
you know.
But I've heard that shit before.
And then Buddy Hackett started fucking
you fucking eighth out.
My cat just got scared.
She was fast.
Fast.
Give me a maybe come here.
She got scared when I use my buddy
hackett voice.
She gets here,
baby.
Come here.
We want to be on TV anymore,
Buddy Hackett voices.
Um,
give me one.
Anyway,
the story wasn't Buddy Hackett.
Um,
when I,
uh,
when I started,
when I started saying that this guy was
stealing material,
Buddy Hackett got really upset because
what bloody Hackett's like an old
school,
like he's a comic from like,
you know,
the catskills days and those guys all
stolen,
terrible,
you know,
they all did each other's jokes and
there was no internet back then.
There wasn't even any fucking TV.
You had some gags and he did them and
nobody knew.
Yeah.
And if you didn't do your gags first,
you know the guy in front of you,
did them,
you know.
You know what's funny is that a lot of
guys from that era,
like everyone,
Bob Newhart's famous for the phone bank.
Yeah.
Bob Newhart's,
famous for it.
He's like on the phone and he'll do one
sided,
the one side of the phone conversation
to Larry's.
But there's a lot of guys from that era
who did the same exact phone bit.
So.
Oh,
well,
um,
while he was yelling at me,
there was a part of me that wanted to
go,
shut the fuck up.
You will cock sucker.
But I didn't want.
He died two weeks later,
which means he was real close to death
that night could have.
So if I yelled at him,
he might've killed over and fucking died
right there,
and it was,
there was a 10 percent,
10 percent of me.
That was like,
why am I listening to this old Douche
bag?
Because my philosophy on old people has
always been that old ass holes were
assholes and they're young.
They just survived.
You know,
they just became an asshole when he
turned 80.
That guy's a Douche bag and I,
I've,
I've thought about yelling at him,
but I said,
you know what,
that's not gonna help anybody.
And I'm like,
what's the point?
This is on television,
so everyone's going to see this guy's
material.
They're going to see what's going on.
Everyone's going to know what happened.
So I did not think.
So here we are with a John Safran neural
linguistic programming freak.
John Heffron is recalibrating his mind.
He said some very negative negative
patterns that he was following earlier
on in his life and he's abandoned all
those.
No more drinking,
no more bad stuff.
John Heffron is all about positive
energy and and,
and Tony Robbins,
right?
Well,
kind of.
Yeah,
but Tony Robbins without the.
I'm walking on on fire and going to a
seminar with $20,000.
Really motivated people.
Yeah.
What is the walking on fire?
Well,
it probably helps you.
It teaches you to walk on fire.
How you would then apply that skill to
other things in your life.
I have no idea.
You know,
because even if you having an argument
with your girl,
you can't go a,
I can walk on fire.
It wouldn't apply to anything else,
but walking on fire guys fighting that
bus boards.
It's great if a guy jumps in front of
you with six boards.
Yeah.
What's the fucking point in breaking
boards?
I don't,
I don't get that.
Or the,
the break in the.
I guess it's your power and a punch but
not.
Well,
that is.
If a guy is standing there,
boards break pretty easily.
That's the sad thing.
Those boards are used for
demonstrations.
They all break.
When I was a kid type window,
whenever we used to open up a new
school,
we would all have to go and do
demonstrations.
And what part of the demonstration was
he out of kick boards,
break boards.
So it was just always seemed so silly.
That's awesome.
Um,
what was I going to say?
We're talking about nero linguistic
stuff.
Oh yeah.
Buddy Hackett.
So you're saying,
so you're doing all this programming and
this programming leads to you better
performances on stage?
Yeah.
It's basically that it just kind of.
We rewires your brain to every.
Everybody.
If something happened to you,
you probably racked similar in every
single situation.
So this Kinda just trains your brain to
maybe take a the best.
It gives you options to handle those
situations where you have zero options,
then you're just going to freak out.
And if you have a few,
you're usually take the best option for
you,
but it also keeps you from doing a
shitty things,
right?
It keeps you from rolling your life.
Yeah.
For me,
it's troubling for me.
What I did is you kind of work
backwards.
You figure out what you want to
accomplish and then you kind of get all
those feelings and what it feels like
once you accomplish those and it kind of
let your brain know this is the way I
want to go.
This is make every decision.
I'm in the right way to,
to obtain that goal.
You know,
I think for me it's,
you know,
some people go,
oh,
that's all,
it's all common sense stuff,
but there's a big difference between a
common sense and uh,
you know,
it's common knowledge or actually
applying it,
but you apply it now you're,
you're all about doing that.
Yeah,
I do.
Before I get on stage,
I do some techniques to get me because
you know,
as stand ups you can get,
uh,
people don't realize it's not what you
travel with guys day your life.
But a lot of times I'm working with
dudes that bugged me.
Cereal,
yeah.
Or whatever.
So you get in a bad mood for 8 billion
different reasons before you get on
stage and then you enter that stage and
you're kind of in a pissy mood,
which then that comes across to the
crowd.
Or what I would do is I would say a
group of guys let's say,
and in my head I would go,
oh,
those guys are going to heckle.
And then I start playing this movie in
my head,
oh,
they're going to heckle right up my
favorite joke.
Oh,
it's going to wrap that thing.
And I start to go like literally play it
out as if it happened.
So then when I got on stage,
I was already mad at these guys that
didn't say anything so I can take the
stage or the little bit more
testosterone.
And then that puts a weird vibe on the
crowd even though those guys might have
not said anything the entire show.
But now I do that with every part of my
life.
And I think a lot of people do,
you know,
you're like,
oh,
look at that girl over there.
I'd asked her,
I asked you probably gonna say no
though.
She probably getting to st o will make
me feel stupid in front of all my other
friends and blah,
blah,
blah.
Just the same.
There's a lag.
There is a definitely a lag because I'm
watching us on the video and it's
totally different from what we're
saying.
It's like John's still talking on the
video,
but right now I'm going to have that
though.
Really was.
Is that because you streamed gay as
fuck?
It's just
we're live streaming video,
you know,
because it.
Would it be better if we were on
blog.tv,
you know,
I mean,
it doesn't really matter about Justin
Dot TV.
Would that be better?
Who cares if people are watching this
care man?
God's saying lag.
He's upset.
Now.
How did,
how did they know there's a lag?
Because he's watching the video and the
sound is different.
No,
no.
The sound and video is the same,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Fifteen years,
uh,
15 seconds delay.
Well,
how the hell do you know there's alive
then?
Probably on a slow,
shitty,
shitty ass in that connection.
Why are you blaming us and aol dial up
John from.
Not only is he a standup comedian,
he also hosted the MMA awards this year,
which was a total fucking disaster.
Really complete.
I didn't say it was a total.
The edited version.
Kim,
on awesome way.
You told it to me.
For me,
for me it was the check cleared.
The check is clear.
It's talk.
Yeah,
the check is coming there,
but for me it was weird that the people
who got to see it on versus got to see
it live as if it was happening.
So there was a lot of,
shoot this guy,
this guy sucks.
I'm just.
Those youth described to me talking
about me hosting.
Um,
I didn't get to those sitting at,
in the safety of their computer and
being maybe 15 or 16 years old,
you would probably think that it's stuff
not realizing that hosting something
like that.
Gentlemen,
the sound.
If you just have to press refresh,
if you press refresh your sound and
video should sync up.
That's what's going on.
Some dude said that the MMA awards were
laying.
Well,
you know what?
Compared to my thing to that lane lane,
this is my thing is,
is lane to what is it is what I don't
get.
There's people compare them and may
awards to what the Oscars.
No,
not much money.
It's just not interesting to watch,
you know,
show it was that.
It was highlighted clip show and people
got to realize I think for the first one
and the budget they had.
That's why,
you know guys like you or Kevin
[inaudible] people.
I was like,
why is it Rogan host?
Why isn't Kevin j like big guys that
people know honestly because they had $0
plus also the,
the hosting thing.
I couldn't have hosted it because I'm a
commentator
anyone and make some,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a human,
I'm a fan and I'm as objective as
possible when it comes to other
organizations.
Like I'm always talking about fate or,
and I'm always talking about Iot and all
these different guys who fight.
Alistair overeem and different guys are
fighting other organizations.
I'm,
I'm a big believer in,
you know,
you have to look at all.
I mean,
if you're a fan,
you have to like all the different
organizations.
You can't just be loyal.
Obviously the UFC is the greatest job
I've ever had and it's a fucking awesome
Gig and I appreciate the hell out of it
and I loved the job.
But as a fan,
you know,
you can't just only follow the fighters
and the fights that are in that
organization.
That's just silly.
I love my favorite thing.
I tweeted this,
so I was watching you do a commentating,
one of the fights.
I love when you call out an entire group
of 20,000
people for billing because I can,
I get mad like we'll just drunk.
The bottom line is I understand that
they didn't like the decision.
That makes sense,
but once the dude is talking,
when they're interviewing,
the dude booing him,
all he did was like Erin Simpson versus
Tom Laurel.
What was the last one like you can't
boot.
Erin Simpson.
The guy thought his ass off.
He got hurt really bad the first round
and came back and won the second and the
third and it was a really gutsy
performance man.
And he had mandarins and even in the
third round he outpaced Tom Lawler and
it was just a great fight overall,
great fight.
And I don't know how anybody couldn't
have enjoyed it.
I mean,
I think in situations like that,
I hate clothes decisions because close
decisions like that man,
it could have gone either way.
And so the fight really took place.
Everybody saw what happened and to
decide that one guy won it or another
guy wanted when it's that close,
I would much rather have a draw.
I think that fight could have easily
been a draw.
You know?
A lot of people thought that Tom Lawler
one,
which I definitely think he won the
first round,
but I think Erin Simpson when the second
and third,
although not in as large a margin second
very slight and the third a little bit
more.
I think if you looked at it on paper you
could say,
well maybe you could give the first
round ten eight,
but the bottom line is forget about all
that.
The bottom line is it was a great fight
and guys should feel like a loser.
Like there's no way Tom Walsh will feel
like a loser after that fight and
there's no way Erin Simpson should have
done booed.
I anytime I've been at live fight or you
hear the people,
I don't get mad,
but I love when people start going start
yelling,
stand him up when they've been on the
ground for maybe 35 seconds.
Yeah.
It's still one more if guys or guys feel
out each other like,
I'm okay with an expired.
I mean I spar MMA is my golf.
I don't smarter really trying to tell
anybody.
I enjoy the workout of it.
But even,
you know,
you have to fill out a guy.
You don't just go,
go and then start start.
You know,
people expect like hockey fight
sometimes where it just erupts
immediately.
They walk out,
they go toe to toe and started.
Well,
I think it's just that the one of the
action is great.
It's so exciting that people want to
keep that part going and then when it
goes to the ground,
the uneducated fans,
if they don't know what's going on,
they get upset,
but promise the referees in small towns,
like when we go to Memphis,
I don't say small towns,
memphis is in a small town,
but we you go outside of Vegas.
A lot of times they use local referees
and these guys,
they're too busy.
They get involved.
They actually too much,
you know,
fight guys,
fight mma,
fighting.
Hey,
you know guys in the guard is working as
guard is trying for an arm bar.
I was trying for something.
I'm going to stand you up and we're
standing out like what the fuck?
Talking about.
You understand what these guys are
fighting,
fighting.
I don't think most people realize the
difficulty.
I mean just have somebody your size if
not a little bit bigger laying on top of
you and then stand up from that
position.
Just letting that person just with their
weight and how hard it is just to stand
up.
What do you mean?
Like if I'm on,
if I'm on my back and you're on top of
me and I and I scrambled and I get it,
that we both,
we stand up together.
That's a huge feat in itself.
It is.
You know,
it might,
it maybe not that.
That shouldn't be that way.
You should get up is if you got up.
It shouldn't be the referee stands.
You have.
I hate all that shit,
but I've always said that if,
if someone like Brock Lesnar can take
you down and molest you for five
minutes,
then that's tough shit.
Tough Shit.
He's got you on your back.
You got to find a way that a way to get
back up to feet and if you can't,
it's five minutes of him punching you in
the face and that's life.
And if your technique to avoid that is
to turn and run in circles so we can't
tackle you,
then do is whenever it gets here and
believe me,
that's going to you.
What's going to decide your career is
going to be fans and with their fans,
like your style,
whether or not you sell tickets,
whether or not you know,
you optimize your potential as a mixed
martial artist and the fans are going to
let you know whether or not they like
your style and if you've got a boring
ass style,
even if you like winning fights,
nobody's gonna give a shit.
They're not going to buy your paper
views.
And that's like,
that's like that's commerce,
you know,
that's how it's supposed to work.
You know,
it's supposed to be let,
let the market dictate what the people
like.
People are not,
not I,
I,
you said you sent a clip the other day,
a tag team,
but what do you think the evolution,
if you were just to pretend to
evolution,
you think maybe 40 years it'd be like
maybe numb chuck's on Iraq,
like on a hook on the side of the cage
where then.
No,
because that's not as fun.
The Fun thing is man to man.
No weapons.
That's what I mean.
You could go the Roman gladiator style,
have dudes have sword fights and there
would be certainly be fucking crazy,
but ultimately I don't think it would be
as enjoyable.
It just be more fucked up because your
champion Musashi,
Musashi beat 62 men and a sword fights,
but unless you're Musashi,
you know what's going to happen,
you're going to get fucking sliced up.
You sucks about that tag team idea is
half the people probably think that's a
great idea.
You know they all came from wrestling.
No,
they don't go to the.
Go to the youtube clip that I posted up
on tag team member,
man.
Every fucking.
What the fuck is this shit now?
Why was that?
What happened?
Then?
What happened from the transition of
wrestling thinking that's an awesome
idea to all those fans.
Wrestling's fake.
Basically,
you know the real.
The evolution is war.
It's like football.
It's like a team of MMA guys on one side
of the field that it's know
I got.
I got a hulk Hogan story for you.
By the way,
when we're at the UFC,
he sat right in front of me and he has
this really weird hair where it looks
like it's a wig almost,
but he pulled out a comb and during the
UFC the whole time he's just calming the
back of his hair and like,
like just like kind of go like this and
like flipping it over his shoulder and I
was just like,
is this really the hall cogan that I
know is combing his hair?
Well,
he probably does it like for like,
it's probably a show like part of his,
his image and it's just because,
I mean,
he's silly.
He's always on when he's out in public,
you know,
he's the hipster dude interviewing him.
Was the shift.
Was that fucking awesome man?
He was really nice guy.
Huh?
It's great guy.
Real Nice Guy.
Every interview you.
Well,
not every interview you've done.
I saw you interview.
There's been,
there's been a fight in the stands right
before you go to talk to them.
They,
uh,
it happened with a semester so long
you're interviewing rocky and there was
a,
there was a thing that happened with
home.
There's always like a little moment
right before it's funny I guess,
or to make them more realistic.
Maybe you could have cage fighting or
where you have to queue fighters and
then random people standing around like
a bar fight.
So then you'd have to worry about
throwing a punch back and have it going
to be robots in a name in the future.
No human chimp hybrids.
People are going to like infuse their
body with chimp DNA and jumped on top of
the cage.
They're going to be so much stronger and
faster.
Well,
is this going to be some definitely just
going to be genetic engineering in the
future.
And when genetic engineering becomes a
reality,
forget about steroids.
Steroids are going to be nonsense.
It's going to be nothing when they get
gene diastat,
you know the,
you ever seen the video of,
um,
there's a,
there's a couple of kids that have been
born with myostatin problems.
And what happens is they develop like a
extreme amount of muscle.
They have all like there's whippets,
there's a dog called a whippet and they
breed these dogs to try to make them
fast,
to make them sleek and run fast and
occasionally they have an error in their
genetics and they get giant muscles.
It looked like they didn't only look
really like photoshop,
but it's a real dog,
like super roided up shredded and no fat
and it's incredible,
but that's all they've done it already
to mice.
They've engineered mice so that these
mice have this mile staten,
a inhibitor situation going on and they
have giant muscles and they can.
They live longer.
I mean,
I'm all for a minute.
I hope all that stuff comes around right
around the time when I'm in my sixties,
seventies,
it's gonna Happen,
man.
I'm going to own it.
Well,
it's.
Everything is going in a direction where
like science fiction,
like the things that we thought of as
being completely ridiculous in the 19
eighties.
This stuff that you would see in a
movie.
I mean it's all real now.
You know,
I mean you see that new Microsoft touch
thing where they have a table and you
can put something on the table and it
recognizes what that something is and it
gives you information on it.
I mean that's like minority of type
shit.
I mean this is all going to happen.
I was talking about that new cell phone
idea that Nokia has where it's a phone
that you're talking and then he flipped
on your wrist when you were doing,
you know,
it's like turns into jewelry.
Yeah.
And it wraps around you.
It's like,
like the bracelets as the old metal
bracelets.
Are you still like flip on your wrist
and that girls would have um,
but it's,
it's a cell phone at the bendable lcd
and they just happened at the other day
and it's pretty much what it is.
They can unsweetened and out,
use it as a phone and then when they're
done,
you just clip it on your wrist.
What's that?
Neo Technology or the took sharkskin the
hallway.
It's all bladed and made the suit that's
almost unstoppable and stuff for like
soldiers were.
You were almost like a wetsuit,
but it's an nothing can get through it.
So it's like Kevin Vocabulary,
but it's thinner and stuff then it's
ever been before.
So he could wear it as a full body and
you can't stab someone with it.
Um,
well regular Kevlar can be stabbed
straight on.
You know,
with a knife you can get through
capital.
But this is some sharkskin is what some
guy invented.
He invented it to stop shark attacks,
but it's not that chain mail stuff.
It's like a wetsuit.
That can't be another messing with that
stuff.
One day I going to have a real iron man
suit.
Yeah,
it's going gonna be crazy if they don't
already know the guys who are gonna look
like Halo.
The dudes from from Halo.
Definitely
all that technology,
like star wars where you're going to
have a helmet that you pull out.
So you know,
because he can't breathe the air
outside.
Yeah,
there's going to be that.
But I think most of the war is going to
be fought.
Like what the CIA's doing a Pakistan
right now,
they've got drones.
These drones are flying over Pakistan,
just launching missiles down on people.
The bottom line is that all things
accelerate.
No things stay exactly where they are
and the only time they degress is when
there's a gigantic national competitor
catastrophe or somebody blows up a bunch
of nuclear weapons and we would go back
to being fucking cave men.
I mean that's the only way things are
going to decelerate,
but the way things are going right now,
they're gonna move and crazier and
crazier direction.
I mean,
we've asked them fast.
We went from,
from bows and arrows to guns to cannons
to and it keeps going and going and
going and now it's fucking drones.
They're firing missiles from the sky.
I mean that's.
And then,
you know,
the Star Wars program they were trying
to do during the Reagan administration,
you know,
they were trying to have it so that they
have satellites that can shoot down
missiles from space.
But apparently that was all bullshit
apparently.
That never really worked in a PR.
There's a gigantic conspiracy wrapped
around the scientists that were involved
in the star wars program because
apparently a fuck load of them have died
under suspicious cause.
Yeah,
there's a,
if you google it,
anybody wants to Google it.
We could google it right now and I'll
put up a link for you guys,
but I don't know if this is a legit,
um,
obviously I don't know if it's a legit
conspiracy theory,
but the star scientists understanding
what I need to conspiracy theory stuff
that you talked about.
Is there one site,
if you,
let's say you're a new guy,
Alex Jones' infowars.com.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Warner's Geo Marconi,
scientists,
death conspiracy theorists.
Mystery of the dead scientists.
Conspiracy with the PD has a little page
on between 1982 and 1990 25 British
based GDC Marconi,
scientists and engineers who work.
Oh,
that's the sting ray.
Oh yeah.
Star Wars defense initiative.
Yeah.
Um,
died under mysterious circumstances.
Wow.
Police investigations found his death to
be unconnected to the same police that
are out Taser and grandmas and shit is.
That was that he did.
It was probably the snacks out of the
vending machine,
probably how aids was created.
There's so many sites on this.
I don't even want to link it because I,
I just.
Yeah,
you know what I'll do.
I'll link the Google search so you do
your own work because uh,
who the fuck knows how many of these
guys are completely crazy.
So I just sent it out there.
Who knows?
Who knows how many guys are completely
out of the fucking mind and who knows
whether or not it's real.
You know,
Star Wars was ringing,
right?
Yeah.
Well the Reagan administration was
famous for um,
a bunch of secret shit was going on.
It says rag and introducing Star Wars.
His announcement of what it was back in
the day.
What are you showing it?
What are you going to show a video or
something?
Don't do that.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Don't put that up.
Star Wars.
It's the whole thing.
Why not weakened?
So people have them introducing star
wars because I don't want to put a,
it's a,
it was just a program where they shot,
supposedly had satellites that can shoot
down missiles from space.
But apparently it was never functional,
never,
never proven to be effective.
They spent billions and billions of
dollars on it and all these scientists
dying.
The big theory was that,
you know,
these guys knew too much and they knew
that it was horseshit and so they had to
kill them off before they talked.
I wouldn't put it past them,
you know,
you get the CIA involved and if you ever
read like economic,
uh,
confessions of an economic hitman and
you find out the shit that our
government does to other countries.
Like they'd kill scientists,
they'll kill anybody.
They don't give a fuck,
you know,
the same people that wanted us to go to
war in Iraq and were willing to lie
about a weapons of mass destruction.
You know,
everybody's a going on and on about
September 11th.
Like,
do you really think the government would
allow innocent people to die during
September 11 so they could go to war?
I don't know,
but do you really think they believed
there was weapons of mass destruction?
Do you really think that we're over in
Iraq and Afghanistan for good reasons
that benefit you and I know and millions
of people have died because of that,
at least a million civilians have died
because of that,
and so if they're willing to do that,
you don't think they're willing to kill
a few thousand here and there.
Of course they are.
And forget about the few thousand that
died during nine slash 11.
The million people that died in Iraq or
human beings,
they're just as legitimate as the people
that died in the twin towers.
I mean,
it's all completely ridiculous.
Someone says,
can we change the topic to something
fun?
I love be praised as his name.
Somebody say,
please look up.
That's the definition of literally you.
You might engage it.
Use that word too much.
You don't know what it means.
Oh,
how do you know what I know what's,
what's that?
The literal translation?
I know it literally,
you know,
I was talking to somebody recently who
has a,
uh,
Joe Rogan UFC,
a drinking game where a guy gets rocked,
know a button.
He prewashed it.
I forgot what he said.
He,
uh,
he prewashed watched it and then bed his
friends a Bj Penn spider monkey lakes.
Is it Turner,
monkey lows?
It's just kind of a weird brand and I
don't know if you've ever said,
I've never heard that.
I might've said it when you do a
hundred.
Yeah.
She's,
I don't.
I might've said that one day.
I forgot.
I said it doesn't inspire them or listen
to this guy.
There's no such thing as a legit
conspiracy theory.
Okay.
Smart man.
Like you fucking know how funnier
people.
There's no such thing as real conspiracy
theories.
Of course there are stupid.
Look up the Gulf of Tonkin.
Gulf of Tonkin incident is a real
conspiracy theory where the government
really did lie and say that there was an
attack on American citizens and that's
what got us into the Vietnam War.
Look up the lookup.
The northwoods document.
The northwoods document is a real
conspiracy that the joint chiefs of
staff drafted up and signed and then it
was vetoed by Kennedy and what it was
was basically they were trying to get
people enthusiastic about a war with
Cuba and they were going to plan attacks
on American civilians.
They were going to blow up an airliner
and blame it on Cuba and say that
Americans were on board.
They were going to attack ships.
They were gonna attack,
Guantanamo Bay.
They were going to throw mortars into at
Guantanamo Bay,
and they were ready for us casualties,
which meant they were willing to kill
Americans in order to get us to go to
war with Cuba,
but these are real.
They look up how fucking cigarettes.
You want to read theory.
How can politicians all want to talk
about drugs and we need to keep drugs
out of schools.
Drugs in this country can't even fucking
come close to the death and destruction
that health problems that cigarettes
have cost,
but yet you don't hear a peep out of
those guys about cigarettes.
Cigarettes kill 400,000
people a year in this country alone.
Every fucking year,
that's a real legit conspiracy where no
one is talking about it.
And the reason why they're not talking
about is because tobacco companies,
finance campaigns,
politician,
those are conspiracies.
What a conspiracy is,
as someone conspires to do something,
there's hundreds of legit conspiracies.
Look up the Iran Contra affair.
I look up the fact that Oliver North and
all those guys were involved in doing
illegal shit in order to,
to help to bring in a.
I just want seeing where they bring
cocaine into,
into the US.
Well,
that's the,
that's the accusation.
And there's a bunch of books that had
been written that and CIA agents who
have said that there was a guy named
Gary Webb who's got a bunch of shit on
that and it was a dude named barry seal
who actually was bringing in cocaine
from other countries.
Got caught and when he was about to go
to trial was murdered.
And that was to go the bringing coke
from at,
um,
those like Afghanistan type countries to
help support them to fight the Russian.
Yeah.
And here's another one is,
you know,
people say,
Oh man,
this is good.
They help us.
And sure,
some CIA I'm sure do that.
But the CIA,
one of the,
one of the planes that's been to
Guantanamo Bay crashed last year in
Mexico with four tons of cocaine.
I'm going to put up that link.
Yeah.
And it didn't even fucking make the news
man would make royders and it didn't,
uh,
it didn't make any of the big news
programs.
I'll put up that link for you guys.
Okay.
But this is the fucking CIA plane.
Yeah.
Polite.
Rupert was the La Compact.
Busted that.
Yeah.
They had a special on hbo or something.
The two [inaudible].
There were two black dudes that were the
ones at all funnel through.
Yeah.
The bottom line about human beings
though is that people are so
lackadaisical when it comes to shit.
And so they,
you know,
you could add that stuff could be on the
news and people would care more about
John and kate.
You know,
John has to pay $10,000
a month in child support and alimony who
actually going to do it?
And that would be big news,
whereas people wouldn't give a fuck
about,
you know,
the CIA selling drugs.
They would,
all you have to do is have one person on
television say it's bullshit and that's
all the.
I mean,
that's all you need to get.
Ninety percent of the people to believe
it.
And uh,
and a lot of those shows and a lot of
the news ones that there's people,
that's what they do for a living,
they say they can put their name in a
database to be an expert about whatever.
And then CNN or Fox or go,
we need a guy that knows about.
And then you're the expert on drug
addiction.
Yeah.
It's been proven that oil companies have
hired scientists to dispute the fact
that human beings have created global
warming.
You know,
who the fuck knows whether or not
they're right or wrong when it comes to
global warming.
And most people that arguing,
they arguing from the point of being a
conservative or being a liberal.
Liberals always say we have to stop and
conservative say there's no connection.
And that's just because they're a bunch
of fucking parents.
They here,
you know,
all these different people rush limbo or
whoever on the radio saying that there's
no connection that you're these shortly
liberals and they just repeat the same
dumb shit and conservatives do that and
then liberals,
they see that fucking Al Gore Cock
sucker and then go Al Gore so that me
and my boards made a billion dollars off
of this fucking climate gate.
If you look at like what Al Gore has
made,
the money that Al Gore's made since an
inconvenient truth came out,
it's fucking staggering.
He's made an incredible amount of money
off of this and the people that would
benefit from all these carbon taxes,
I mean,
they're setting this up to make money
and that's what they're doing.
No one's doing this.
There's,
I'm sure there's a few scientists
they're doing with the right intentions,
but most of the politicians have to push
them in as they have ulterior motives
and they're trying to make money off of
this shit.
Hey,
Joe Rogan.
Did you hear Johnny Bananas?
Twenty one at Gmail Dot com says,
who'd you hear that the y chromosome is
evolving faster than the x chromosome?
That's because we're men.
Bitch.
Johnny bananas were the only ones with
the why.
The women don't get the why.
The why is the future.
Yeah.
I just saw,
I just saw a documentary about that,
uh,
that males are disappearing because of
all the chemicals.
Yeah.
I've heard that too,
that that's why guys act more girlish.
Now.
If you look at,
well,
that's,
there's a surplus of men.
There's the,
when there's a search,
when there's a surplus of men rather men
act more aggressive and grow more facial
hair and become more masculine and have
more testosterone.
When there's a surplus of women,
men tend to relax and they tend to be
more feminine and they tend to shave
more and be more metrics.
Actually,
this one was about that.
The other chemicals that probably our
parents,
our parents parents did in the sixties,
all the plastics and all that kind of
stuff where they said wasn't bad for
you.
Now they realized it is and for some
reason that those chemicals affect men
more like defined the alligators that
live by,
let's say Dow in,
in the,
in the swamps had smaller balls,
then alligators,
um,
you know,
generations earlier that all those
chemicals were shrinking.
The alligator balls.
I don't know what job you have that
that's your guy.
That one guy goes,
I'm going to measure it out,
get her balls.
Yeah,
you know,
I'm going to measure it and we might
need this data later.
But that's what,
that's what they say is just from all
the chemicals and stuff that men are
acting less like Matt and producing more
sperm I think in the sperm.
Less the girl.
No less from like,
so young guys now have less sperm than
their dad probably have,
which it should be the internet,
you know,
we're getting rid of more spring in our
guides
because we're jerking.
You didn't have it.
I bet it's very much more difficult for
your dad or your dad about masturbation
because they used to have to set up a
projector that pull the shades down,
pull the screen,
run that little 16 millimeter black and
white old lady molestation nowadays too.
I wonder what the odds are.
Well,
it actually goes down.
I don't think it's dumb.
You don't have or go even back further
than that.
That was guys had to put up the
projector.
Even go the guys before that had the
paint stuff on walls in caves and then
you know that there's way more people
now.
So there's way more molestation.
But per capita I'm wonder.
I wonder the Japanese,
the Japanese believe that if you show
all that shit,
you show rape and molestation and crazy
sex.
You know,
like that's why they're in a school.
Girls on that shit.
They feel like that.
It gets it out of your system.
Then if you watch like violence in in
video and movie form,
that somehow or another,
it gets it out of your system.
Why did they blur all their porn?
Now?
The only blur.
The pubes yeah,
that's weird.
Wait,
you're allowed to get fucked by a
technical,
but he can't see it.
Can't you see pussy or indeed not bad
witness reload.
But if you squint,
like in the old days in the news,
if you squint you can see this magic and
then I find myself like squinting going.
There's other porn that I can be
watching that's way more like the old
old school kind of French kind of
European pork.
Do you remember my news when you're,
um,
the old days when you would go on the
road and you'd go to hotel rooms and the
dirty movies would be scrambled,
but they would only be like legally.
Yeah,
if you can get online through them and
you'd see like a Ted that would go into
the mouth and you,
you'd have enough to jerk off to.
It used to be able to use to be able to
get like a three or four minute preview
to see if you want it.
So you'd have 10 and hit the second
preview.
I was proud of myself.
I would,
I would get hard.
And then as the preview was going to be
done in 15 seconds and with the vhs,
like if we borrowed from somebody you
could see like what their thing was
because when you put it in and hit play
whatever scene,
you know that,
that they just had stopped after they
were done.
So you're like,
really?
That's the thing.
You did someone have a bit about that.
Chris rock had a bit about that,
about you know,
how he went.
Turns out one of his porns and he had
left at a certain scene.
But then because of the vhs tape,
when he went to it the next time it was
a different scene is like someone's been
watching my.
That's so true.
Right?
That was.
Yeah.
I remember.
I remember renting vcrs,
this 18 vcr.
And then leave it in there when you take
it back or something or you'd rip off of
the.
I remember,
I like birthday parties.
My mom would go to the library and rent
a movie projector just to show like
Moody's birthday party.
Do you think the CIA had a hand in Gary
webs death?
I don't know the story behind other Gary
Webb die,
so the tablets going to be announced
next week.
Uh,
supposedly by apple and they don't know
what the name is.
It's like I slate or ipad now I'm
sitting in bed at like four in the
morning am I can think of what could it
be called?
And I'm thinking why wouldn't they?
It like I tag whatever they call it.
It,
it's like a go online at [inaudible] dot
TV.
Just in case,
you know,
I'm,
I'm addicted to domain names for
riddick.
I've got,
I've got like 8 trillion that I would
never for any reason.
Do you have a lot?
What's some of them that you own?
I've owned a.
let's see,
this is back in aol days like it
obviously.
I never did.
Lol.
Stop,
stop,
stop.
This Gary Webb guns are asking that they
were talking about the whole dropped all
the stuff about the CIA and the,
the,
the is and everything.
She committed suicide according to the
coroner.
Shot himself in the face twice.
Well,
if it didn't work the first time,
definitely
I guess.
Yeah,
that was the guy that said all the
cocaine guy.
Credible sources.
Cook.
No.
Yeah,
this is the,
this is the guy that was releasing all
the information about the CIA selling
cocaine.
Alright,
hold on a second.
Copy this.
Paste it for you guys.
Yeah,
that was an interesting uh,
because when the Iran contract stuff was
going on,
I think I was like,
you know,
11 or 12 in there.
I had a oliver north for president t
shirts.
Yeah.
I didn't even.
That's an interesting shot himself in
the fucking face twice.
That's hardcore.
Oh,
ouch.
Hm.
Who knows.
Anyway,
what are you talking about?
The tablet?
No,
our addiction.
Addiction to domain names.
Like what?
What's some domain names that you did
you buy?
Because I,
I'll think of something usually when I'm
really stoned.
Bye.
John [inaudible].
John F funds a fag.
John Headphones.
A loser should've.
Should
are scam.
Scam.
Because you always see those at the
first.
Whatever the whatever you're looking,
you always see the word scam at the top
and then when you click on whatever it
is,
it just pro whatever you're looking.
Because I think naturally if you're
looking to buy something,
you see the scam,
you're like,
well I'll go to the negative first.
Oh,
some dude said it was doug stand hopes
bit about his mom with the porno.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That makes sense.
It's awful.
There's a company called rip off report
and this is like,
I don't know how this is legal at all.
If somebody's mad at your company or
something like that,
they can put something on there.
And what this company does is it uses
spam techniques where it spans like
message boards and all this shit all day
long.
So Google puts it on the top of your
list.
So my friend has a fashion company that
does like dresses and stuff like that.
And the first thing that comes up when
you google is rip off report,
this person's ripping you off and blah
blah blah.
And Michelle are my friends,
like how do I get rid of this kid?
They're like,
well if you give us $2,000,
we'll take it off.
It's like,
what
second?
So the company that reports on people
for scams,
they're basically just extorting.
Yes,
it's called ripoff report and then in a
funny thing is that you receive them and
they'll take your name off of it.
Holy Shit.
A rip off report dot Com and it seems
like it's a legit company.
So if you have a problem with,
you know,
like somebody's business or something
like that,
you can say you can write a letter like
this person ripped me off and stuff like
that.
That's extortion,
extortion.
And if you go online there's a lot of
people suing this company or is it about
12 different lawsuits going on for this
company right now,
but she's been trying everything to get
the shit off.
Like she's.
She was on TV the other day.
Doesn't matter still.
First thing you google her name,
it comes up.
Is that her name?
Michelle window.
Am I c h e l l e Dot Wendel w e n t.
it's somebody like that.
I don't know how successful,
but either way it's people like that
don't have the report.
Wow.
Don't have the money to go after her to
go after them,
you know what I mean?
That's pretty expensive.
I'm in.
I was going to sue a company recently
and it was just,
it ended up being just so much money
that you had to go,
well,
do I want to use that just to say that
I'm right
or do you just save,
you know,
both of those people are ex employees to
that wrote those things real.
She fired.
Yeah.
It seems like there'd be some kind of
like libel or something.
Yeah.
Well they're getting sued,
but I mean,
but the whole thing that's weird about
it is,
is that it's like,
uh Oh,
what was that?
Even time
already should have fear just showed up.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that crazy Jew.
We didn't even call him and tell him to
come here.
I have a special guest.
My special guest this week is John Half
Ron.
It's not already should fear what is
that mumbles over her or I should fear
came because probably he knows I got the
best weed.
Let's talk about our latest twitter,
which is twitter.
I've had a lot of people ask me how many
percentages of artists' twitters are
have to do with suicide or no,
I was going to say a shitty of some type
of something.
Leaving his Bong Hall.
He talks about someone says something
disappointed that you're not getting
high.
The reason why we're not getting high it
was because up until a few moments ago,
my little baby was in the house and my
mom and the baby and we're in the media
room right now and
there's no ventilation up in this bitch
high.
He's down here with a shotgun in his
mouth.
He's been doing all this shit lately.
It's so now she's coming to get you a so
you got to call her because I'm doing.
Where are you at next?
Where are you at this weekend?
Right?
I'm a nowhere this week or next week and
then I'm in the following week.
Sorry,
have you about deleting your mind space?
Because I'm actually to the point where
I'm thinking by deleting my mind space,
I still put a blogs.
I still will take a blog.
Whenever I put up a log I'll.
I'll throw it nine out of 10 times.
I'll throw it up on my space as well,
just because I think more people
a few more.
We'll read it my space because it has
the date and you don't have to be a fan
to actually see the dates,
so you don't have to be a fancy that
taste.
So you see there's two different things.
Facebook is really confusing.
There's a fan page.
I have a fan page or something else that
you don't have to be a fan to to see the
dates.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it's a.
what's the two?
It's a fan page and a group and the
group.
It's so annoying.
Facebook,
so knowing with this,
but yeah,
group.
Facebook by the way is A.
I don't want any more pillows sent to
me.
I don't want any.
I have.
I don't see any of that.
You turn off any kind of event.
Pillows are blessings.
I appreciate that.
How do you.
It's in your settings,
so confused.
It's like there's this pillow fight,
so you'll go to your thing and there'd
be like 50 people hit you with pillows.
I want to find the dude who invented
glitter kegs,
glitter tags.
I don't want anybody putting my wall.
Who would've ever thought that would be
popular?
Have you been to the mall and glitter
your iphone
or people that can tag you.
Like I'll get comics that I'll have like
their video on youtube and they'll tag
me and then suddenly their video of them
on is on my.
It's my,
it's like my property,
that's my grass.
Stay off my grass
and Joe were talking about this the
other day.
We have a friend that doesn't want,
you know,
people.
He's very private,
but since somebody just posted a photo
of them and now every single person that
that person is friends with can see
like,
you know,
please go right to the photo.
Yeah.
Private.
Facebook's a mess.
Yeah.
The security settings are sketchy.
And there was a dude who was a former
facebook employee that was talking about
it,
you know,
divulging all the information but how
they do things and
well,
you know,
that's how they're doing.
A lot of people are seeing a lot of
people's identity is to go you.
And I'll get enough information from
your site just in general that I,
that I can then use that to piece mail.
Well,
how about this?
There was a failure stuff.
A bunch of dudes are getting scammed.
This is very common where guys are
pretending to be chicks and they're
pretending to be tricks online.
And some dude was posing as a model and
scam.
$15,000
out of some doctor in Florida.
Sent pictures,
photoshop naked pictures and,
and apparently this dude had a girl's
voice,
like a really feminine voice.
I'll put up the link for you guys,
but it's fascinating how fucking
gullible dudes.
I like.
How the fuck do you not know?
Did you put up the link to somebody
wanted to know about what you're talking
about earlier with the mice?
No,
I didn't put up the milestone inhibitor
thing,
but I'll put it out.
I'm going to put,
put up this like put a John from twitter
up there though,
right?
I need follow up.
John [inaudible] followed on her
1000 followers finally got exit forever.
I tried to keep mine too.
I go in spurts with twitter,
sometimes I want a twitter three in a
row,
but then I'll then I'll feel bad and
then won't do any for like a day or two,
but then I realized everybody's
following a lot of people so it's not
that annoying.
It's weird how like,
it's so different.
Like my space,
I had no problem getting frames on or
whatever,
but with twitter people are a little bit
more picky because they have to read
your shit everyday.
That again,
it's different how like twitter,
like some people are huge on twitter,
you know,
you wouldn't think there they are like
twitter makes no sense to me.
Now numbers why?
You know,
like Aston Kutcher is the most popular
magazines and it goes on CNN and he
talks about his twitter on CNN and Larry
King every day,
but he's not even a quarter.
That fucking dinosaur.
Nobody gives a shit about it.
Larry King,
the young people with twitter don't give
a fuck about Larry King,
but they certainly give a fuck about
Aston Kutcher,
that handsome devil with his elderly
wife.
They love that dude.
Wonder how long are going to keep her
because Ashton's only like fucking 27
years old,
right?
Isn't it?
He's got me in his thirties now.
Like.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's say he's 35.
Then she's 47 at 20 years.
Forty years.
She's going to be 57.
Who?
That's a tough sell.
I think it's great.
Yeah.
I'll probably go 20 years backwards.
He hangs out with Bruce Willis video.
Maybe Bruce Wells takes a degrees or
asked.
Yes,
exactly.
That's weird.
I don't want to hang around with some
dude who made babies with my wife was
fucking her like every night sleeping in
bed with her and coddling with.
But you know what?
I'm not that open minded.
Maybe Ashton's really open mind or maybe
it's just hanging out with him.
Awesome.
I'm in with the Hollywood crowd was so
cool.
We hang out and party b while bruce is
like,
go get me a beer.
Oh,
get your peer.
Actually,
accidents got better creative.
Bruce.
Nowadays I dare you.
I dare you with those terrible movies he
makes.
How dare you say that you'd be
motherfucker the fuck up boy.
But like how many shows his ass in
fucking producing right now and that's
doing some news to share that I did in
my head.
And they all suck.
Every single one of them still make
Bruce Willis is bruce.
You see the butterfly effect?
How many people?
How many?
How many people have asked him saved in
a movie?
Good.
Good point.
I've never watched it.
I know,
but I'm trying to.
The Butterfly.
Awesome comedy.
Have you seen that is awesome.
Unintentional comedy boost.
What?
Action flicks.
Okay.
All the die hards.
You know how many people as Ashton
Kutcher killed him?
Was that movie The monkey moving?
18 monkeys.
12 monkeys.
Monkeys.
Six months.
Numbers International.
Roy?
Yeah,
it was.
He probably got lost or died on the way
over here is cheap as carpet with him.
Ask Him because she was pretty selfish
as far as movies.
He say he didn't save the world.
Anybody.
Do you have a video we can play while we
go
for a.
we'd break.
Oh,
that's a good idea.
This the video work done.
Does it?
It just wasn't set up for that.
What can you play that?
While we go do a,
we'd break pick up already and we're
going to go smoke some weed and the show
will be infinitely funnier in five
minutes.
Um,
let's play global thermonuclear only 31
years old.
She's Sam.
These bitches know what time?
Everything to.
Hold on.
Let me get something.
How often do I get poned pew?
How do you say?
Poned in real life and say,
that's nice to say.
Someone wants to know how often,
how often they get tapped.
I get tapped at least every month at
least once a month.
Last month I got tapped one,
two,
three times.
I got tap three times last month and was
because uh,
moving back to la from Colorado,
I was in,
I was out of shape.
I wasn't training that much and you
know,
you roll with good guys to get tapped.
Especially when you're tired.
When you roll like after the first guy,
the first guy you know,
you drill the way we do it a 10th planet
is your drill for the first half hour,
40 minutes and that gets you tired,
but you still have good energy.
But then the first role you have full
energy,
you know the first role,
you feel great,
but if you roll with a tough guy and
everybody attends planet,
I mean your role with Brown belts and
purple belts,
all those dudes are tough.
All those dudes are capable of tapping
you out and then it's a matter of how
much endurance you have because if you
know,
you put yourself in bad positions,
you know,
especially if you're pulling guard all
the time because I'm trying to work on
my bottom game now to try to work on my
guard.
And if you,
if you get tapped,
I get tapped.
Shit,
I get tapped all the time.
Once a month.
If you don't,
if you don't get tapped,
you either not rolling with good people
or you're not trying.
You're not opening yourself up.
If you don't open your game up,
you don't improve.
You gotTa,
you gotTa.
First of all,
if I just wanted to get on top all the
time and always hold position and not
take any chances.
You could go a year without getting
tapped.
But if you want to learn and you want to
develop your game,
you can't worry about being tapped.
When you get tapped,
you got to go,
okay,
that's one more way that I won't get to.
Our friend Scott got me in this crazy
arm bar from inside my guard.
I was,
I had him in my car and he got me in an
arm bar that's never happened before.
It's some crazy thing where as you scoop
under the leg to try to toss the guy and
get him in an arm bar.
He has this way of locking your arm with
his leg and they pulls on it.
It's real dangerous felony.
My elbow was going to go and I was like,
you motherfucker.
I'm like,
I to get that.
And then I had them show it to me,
but now he tried to do it again,
uh,
the day before yesterday.
And he couldn't get me in it,
but it's just because he got me in it.
Hey,
you got in.
Did you let yourself in the housekeeper?
Awful Shapiro,
the Ari Shapiro,
Ladies and gentlemen with Lola,
she's lonely.
And she goes,
no,
you got a video.
Yeah,
looking for something good.
Arash fierce.
You're already come.
Say Hi to the American public.
All 518 people.
You don't even know where the fuck we
were over here.
Look at this already close to Ma'am to
sexual.
It's weird,
Huh?
Oh,
watch out here comes a goofy had it's
going to come in and put you where you
are.
What?
I'm looking for.
Videos that video,
uh,
bring my mass in.
Um,
he'll,
he'll create problems.
Whatever.
I'm standing with that door a gate.
And I was like,
come on killers around.
Doesn't know me.
I need somebody who knows.
I wouldn't come in if I saw johnny.
Brutus is small.
You have some.
He's not going to do anything.
But here's something interesting.
If Johnny thought you were scared,
he booked.
Were you afraid of bitch?
Who Take advantage?
They don't have fun.
Good man.
What do you,
what did you find that?
That six.
It's a six minute special on how this
local person is given a medical
marijuana to,
to his autistic kid legal.
Oh yeah,
that's the one where the kid is all
fucked up and he gives a little pieces
of it every day.
Yeah,
that's really interesting.
In six minutes,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to just show you a little
clip of video so that we can go get high
and then we come back.
This is going to be a totally fucking
different show and talk for a little bit
like filmy pitches where they're saying
that will cure autism or autism.
It helps autism people that have autism.
Yeah,
they're kids.
This,
this guy has a medical marijuana
prescription for his kid because this
kid has autism and yeah,
this is a local guy.
Couldn't nothing was working,
nothing was helping and what are the
positive effects almost.
It just relaxes.
It calmed him down.
You're going to go full screen with that
bitch still working on which we're still
trying to iron out clunky.
We need to get a good program and we're
trying to.
Which I right?
How smart is my master?
If he's real smart,
we'll bring them in after the break to
get a breakfast session identification
for weeks.
We got to push the time,
the patient pills,
boxes,
medical marijuana is nothing new but
new.
That's one issue in particular.
Could children ticket to share Calvin
here with an incredible story about one
families fight for their son.
Micah in Victoria.
When you say that sounds so shocking to
so many,
but California's prop 2:15,
the compassionate use act was passed by
voters a decade ago and it tells a lot
of seriously ill patients with a
doctor's recommendation to use marijuana
legally,
but what about for children?
We did find this one family with a truly
remarkable tale to tell us in this case,
Ela exclusive report.
Tell me what the school's like.
This is Sam 10 year old who lives with
his dad,
his mom and his sister Lucy in northern
California.
Sam has autism from age two to age.
Sam's disorder made him violent and
aggressive.
His parents,
Steve and Angela were truly living a
nightmare every day
where he was hurting other children at
school and it places a lot of times
would be enlightened store and he would
just escalate this bolt off and go and
hit another child in the face.
One time he pulled the TV game,
Dr Moore,
all the furniture and I got and I had to
put him in a food for maybe an hour.
We just were.
His whole body was spasming.
It was just later crying and older.
Sam's parents worked with expert doctors
who recommended a succession of
conventional prescription medications
like risperdol and a host of others,
but Sam just gained 20 pounds and became
harder to handle,
so
we were like,
okay,
he's getting more interest,
is getting bigger and stronger now.
Least 20 pounds bigger from the
resperdol the child,
but we had grown to love was gone.
It was just like when you looked at and
when you talked to him,
he had just disappeared.
Finally at their wit's end and faced
with the very real prospect of needing
to institutionalize their son.
Sam's parents decided to try something
unconventional and controversial.
Last year they began treating Sam with
medical marijuana.
When you think about it,
it really is the perfect medication for
that kind of behavior.
It's just very calming.
So this is the medicine right here.
Steven Angela got a recommendation from
a medical cannabis doctor.
They told Sam's pediatrician about their
plan,
and Steve Grew Sam's new medicine in
their backyard.
We had six plants.
This is where Steve took out his tomato
plants to grow and then harvest the
cannabis from the marijuana flowers.
He could make a concentrated form what
people refer to as this ball represents
roughly four months of doses for Sam
later.
Steve softens the cannabis with heat,
then takes what appears to be just a
speck of pond.
Sam's Joe's for the day.
What affected the medical cannabis have
on Sam was the first time we did it.
We just wanted to do,
um,
to see if it would work at all.
And it was just an amazing experience.
I can't,
I'll never forget it,
you know,
to watch what happened to him.
It was just like this Bush and doesn't
tend to upgrade and this,
uh,
you know,
obsessiveness,
it's just like,
it just went away just like it just
calmed him down.
Well,
we were with the family.
We watched Steve put Sam's daily.
Joe sent a piece of melon and take it to
him.
Within roughly 20 minutes.
Be Effects were clear,
were earlier.
Sam had been animated an antsy after
eating his Spec of Sam became calm,
relaxed,
and social.
As a mother,
how would you feel about people saying
to you that you're getting your son's
stone everyday for?
At first I was very concerned about
that,
but recently I've been sharing the story
with more and more people,
you know,
friends and coworkers,
and I find that your,
the more I tell people,
the more I share with people,
the more comfortable I am with it.
It has saved our lives and I think about
what it's done for our son.
Could stamp story help others.
Respected La area pediatrician
Christopher toles shirt says,
we don't know enough about cannabis for
kids,
for all the parents out there whose
children may have autism.
I think the message here is that this is
intriguing information that needs more
research before we can confidently say
that marijuana is a safe and effective
treatment for once,
but for this California family,
medical marijuana has literally being an
answer to their prayers as homecoming
for their son.
It was just
medication that we saw on that gave us
the results that we were always hoping.
I mean,
I think that really is a kid that he was
happy,
he was smiling.
He had lost that for so long and it was
so sad and wondered if we'd ever seen it
again.
It just feels like I have more control
to help my son instead of the baby on
Dr.
May have the best intentions with Sam.
I want to do what's best for my son.
For him.
One important notes that Sam's parents
tell us that they have followed the
letter of the law regarding his
medication and that they've wrote only
the amounts of marijuana that prompts
you.
15 allows the medication is for Sam and
for nobody else.
Now,
Sharon,
does he?
Does he take his medication every single
day?
You know,
they,
they started off at 7:00
in the morning he was going to get,
then they would give him a second dose
in the afternoon,
but after two years it started as an
eight.
He's now 10.
They sometimes don't have to give it to
him and only give it to them as needed,
which is incredible.
It really has changed his behavior
according to them.
Alright,
sure.
Terrific story.
Thank you for the reporting.
For more on Sam's story and information
on treating children with autism,
go to our website,
Kateel a.com.
I'm
sure you'll find shares report to the
American Academy of Pediatrics.
I want to party with that kid.
I was listening to this online last
night.
Dr.
Drew was on and he was talking about
marijuana and how he was just so.
He's just always
fight that.
He's like,
they're just,
they're just dumb.
People were so silly about his take on
marijuana,
medical marijuana,
people that want medical marijuana.
He thinks they're silly and they're
ruining America and he thinks that all
drugs are bad.
That the one state of mind and state of
mind that you're currently in is the
only one.
He shouldn't be drunk.
You shouldn't be high.
You shouldn't be drugged up.
He does not get it.
That is not true.
There are drugs that are terrible for
you.
The ones that you see on his show,
the crystal Meth,
the fucking heroin and Oxycontin,
those are all fucking horrible for you.
That's a guarantee.
But zoloft.
Well,
for some people it's not.
I don't know.
You have to ask him,
but the what he says about marijuana is
ridiculous because he lumps marijuana in
with like heroin and drugs.
Yeah.
It's.
I'd rather get my kids.
There's so much proof that it's not
addictive and it's like my argument
about it,
it's like anything can be addictive.
You can get addicted to cheeseburgers.
If you're a fucking retard,
you could be one of those dudes who gets
addicted to Washington,
his hands.
You know,
people become compulsive.
Bullshit.
Perfect example.
People get addicted to things,
van.
That's what we do.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't have the
things have other people telling you
they'd benefit from it.
That's what's fucking stupid about this
whole marijuana thing.
There's no heroin activists.
There's no,
you know,
there's no crystal Meth,
uh,
activists.
There's like,
you've got to get on crystal meth or
heroin,
but people keep telling you that weed as
enhance their lives and help the way
they think and made them a better person
and that fuck doesn't want to believe
that dude in the,
uh,
in the article was that Commerce
Margaret magazine article in Fortune,
Fortune magazine.
Yeah.
The one dude was on the case the first,
like six people case study.
He said he's never gotten high,
but he smokes it constantly,
all day long.
All it helps us with is like arthritis
or whatever it is.
Will we barbecued?
If you keep going,
if you,
if you.